it's been one year since Israel launched
Operation protective edge on the Gaza
Strip during the fighting author and
journalist max Blumenthal was on the
ground in Gaza his book the 51 day war
is about what he saw there and he's with
me now thank you for joining me max good
to be with you describe to me the scope
of the destruction you saw there and how
people in Gaza are still affected today
well when I arrived it was the beginning
of extended ceasefire the first extended
ceasefire of the 51 day war and I spent
five days from sunup to sundown in the
rubble all across the border regions of
the Gaza Strip which are in a really
tough neighborhood because they border
Israel and this is the area that Israel
comprehensively destroyed destroyed
18,000 homes
when the UN had warned before this war
that the Gaza Strip would be
uninhabitable by 2020 now it's currently
uninhabitable I went into eastern Rafa
which is the southernmost city in the
Gaza Strip and so I'm wandering through
this just this theater of destruction
and I meet a 19 year old kid named
Mahmoud abu saeed who could barely speak
was clearly traumatized and his family
members told me he had been taken as a
human shield taken upstairs in his home
and he took me into his room where his
rally soldiers stripped him stood him by
his window and shot over his shoulders
in order to snipe to death two young men
who live next door the answer to this
might be obvious but when you talk to
people there who do they blame they
blame Obama during the war we heard
Barack Obama say he's heartbroken by
these images of dead Palestinian
children including Palestinian children
who were stored in an ice-cream cooler
at the Kuwaiti hospital in Rafah after
Israel threatened to bomb the al-najjar
Hospital this image of five infants in
death shrouds in an ice-cream cooler
because there was nothing left to cool
their corpses I think is the defining
image of this war what was America's
involvement during the Gaza war well the
u.s. involvement was supplying Israel
with everything it needed down to mortar
rounds in order to destroy civilian
infrastructure and the Gaza Strip
one year later has this huge been lifted
or improved at all not one home that I
know of has been rebuilt so there's
100,000 people who are rendered homeless
and these attacks are still wandering
around kind of like ghosts
what does it mean for the young people
in Gaza for these people who have grown
up and have now seen three wars the Gaza
Strip is a ghetto of children most
people in the Gaza Strip are under the
age of 18 and a substantial percentage
of those who are under the age of 18 are
under the age of seven which means
they've known nothing in their lives but
these three major assaults that began in
2008 these children are all suffering
almost all of them from continuous
traumatic stress disorder as a Jew it's
difficult because especially for young
people people under the age of 25 or
under the age of 20 most of them have
never met a Jew who didn't threaten to
harm them who didn't abuse them
the only relationship they have with
Judaism is to this state that's holding
them under siege and constantly
attacking them that claims to speak on
behalf of world Judaism but I was gonna
relate this story of talking to Waseem
jamali who's a 15 year old the 15 year
old younger brother of Salim Somali the
19 year old guy who was killed on video
recorded by an international solidarity
movement volunteers as he searched for
his family in Shibuya lilulu and what
seemed broke down in tears when I asked
him about Solomon his relationship with
him he was his best friend you know
after the interview was over and he
recovered I said what do you want to be
when you get older and of course he said
I want to be a fighter
[Music]